[Music]
in solitary vacation news all by herself
that sense lonely submitted by I'm
looking at you Joe haha
he was like the extreme zoom yeah that
they have on the icy store Burnett and
overworked South Koreans are going to
prison to relax risen for reals so not
real prison Oh prison crimes because I
don't know I don't know how I could
relax with a [ __ ] dick in my ass
well you'd be surprised after about ten
minutes you will relax you have to run
give it ten minutes and then you'll
relax ten minutes but don't take any No
ten minutes is quite a while yeah I mean
for the first day I'm in jail my booty
kind of luscious so I know people gonna
be after it's high commodity what makes
you think your booty saucers is pretty
nice I watched it I mean I've seen it
okay Archie I didn't say anything
judge him cuz he knows a good little
booty pop like you would never suspected
but he can pop his booty pretty well
yeah my buddy that flat he went into JK
autopilot was like what's going on
that's crazy
there's too many things going on in
Korea right now man why would you go to
prison and relax
Koreans yes oh this place is a stress
reduction center with a prison theme oh
we've been to something like that oh you
have not the stress reduction but where
what country were we in you mean escape
room no it's Alan yeah and then the
hotel that we're at was prison-themed
o-q prison it was like legit like a say
inside it was cool cuz like the door of
the hotel room when it closes it I was
like that whole vault thing it has a
window you put your food in there's bars
on
you've made there we got to yeah just it
was bar like oh my god this is awesome
hey honey I'm gonna drop the soap I
thought the whole thing was like old
school World War two European prison it
was weird so I thought was cool I want
to hear more of that I want to see you
photos I want to know that's how I feel
when I see people going to Alcatraz you
know and they were like you know pink
t-shirts and flip-flops and [ __ ] and
they're walking around Alcatraz taking
pictures like that's cool or like
getting behind bars going like no but
then I have an authentic face it was
like no you were smiling remember you
were on the toilet like this oh well did
you guys have the exposed toilets I
don't know it was weird though it's
crazy it's like you're next to the
shower and it was like enclosed it's
like going to Auschwitz or one of these
things and and like standing there
behind it no pants or whatever like that
no one it might make sure the gas fumes
and they're like this yeah right would
be something like that
no no anything like that is respectable
but it's a it's a jail themed hotel that
makes it okay yeah yeah no one was
really in prison there he did go to a
concentration camp and both me and I
really kinda like cheering up and crying
that's pretty sad yeah that would be
yeah yeah I didn't get to go but I was
in Germany and you just feel in the air
man we were in Germany - yeah I was in
Berlin and just standing there and like
we're all the Nazis walked and [ __ ] it
was eerie it's eerie for sure you'll
feel it I want to go it's pretty dope
you should go European Tour's are like
you want to it's like I want to go and
get sad like you guys no you don't get
sad no and we could talk about how sad
it made us
you can't talk about how sad I mean you
could look there there's no connection I
speak for all the people who went to
Berlin right now so yeah her daddy's
born at Berlin really always just
Germany I don't know what city that's
cool what's his favorite color cut up in
Munich blue oh cool
this place is called prison inside me
inside me inside me okay unfortunate
titling what Koreans chose the title
they don't speak English
I see where it just doesn't translate
well maybe it just doesn't wrap
that's [ __ ] right there that's like a
[ __ ] prison it gets you and it just
holds you it doesn't let go
poetic it's for people who are
overworked cuz in South Korea they're
known for working very hard and like
really long hours during the week and so
at this place mmm we gotta make it look
like a prison how relaxing huh yeah they
don't have like a bed in the place it's
just sleep on the floor we have prisons
are hella nice dude what the hell looks
like an apartment you're it's like you
sleep on the floor
sleep on the floor you have a toilet in
the corner with like a wash pull and
then you need out of a bowl on the floor
no then they give you well yea cuz they
give you your food through like a slot I
don't know if it's explained but why a
prison thing I I know the point of this
I feel like okay go
so I'll just think about this the other
day how like you know when we're like
all caught up in work and we like to go
out into the mountains and stuff and
just disconnect I think there's so like
metropolitan it's really hard like I
don't know if camping is it even at
being there so it might be really hard
for them a disconnect if they're really
overworked they probably want to go
somewhere where there's an excuse to
turn off your phone don't talk to your
family just gotta get some me time
and that's probably why they want to do
that that's pretty cool too I actually
read a little bit about this earlier if
they put their hands on the bars like
someone comes up with a baton [ __ ]
hits them on the hands this is silly or
like they make the biowarfare poison
like you know how they take a dump
inside of the toilet and then they make
that [ __ ] raw [ __ ] and a yeah they get
like [ __ ] arrows out of toothbrush
they make like little stabbing things
out of Chevy's when they kind of pass
the food they [ __ ] shoot that [ __ ]
and try to murder the people that are
giving fake a didn't she
no right it's not that crazy is that
legit prison they get like a [ __ ]
hairdryer break it apart and make like a
tattoo machine with it yes like you
gotta walk and hold a guy's pocket that
[ __ ] always is jarring for me when I see
a dude like in any TV show holding
another dude's pocket on my pocket oh
the pocket yeah well I think you got
really popular in the scared straight
thing yeah like if you hold the inside
of a dude's bar like this [ __ ] yeah like
like I'm walking it's like you're my
busines Oh everyone that a butt [ __ ] do
you like 20 times yeah like you like
your butt is like [ __ ] like the
sleeve yeah it's like a three inch PVC
pipe like this leaves about to throw up
[Laughter]
you can tell when a booty holes been
ravaged in it and if it hasn't yeah so
tonight stay here would cost about a
hundred and forty six dollars genius
yeah and there's a pretty good it's a
good business they give them [ __ ] and
you have to treat them like [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah I don't think they treat people
like [ __ ] on my head thank you you want
to can you leave yeah and so they're
also saying that they lock the doors
from the outside but they teach they
teach the guests how to unlock it from
the inside in case of an emergency and
there's also a panic button if they want
to leave like they just need more re
eyes out there so they can go camping
what Sarria outdoor sports type of store
and it's his original equipment
incorporate some point they do they take
your phones and stuff before you enter
the gym you do that's good bones they
take yeah they pretty much just it's
sort of like solitary confinement like
you're going there for the experience of
solitary confine I just went camping
over the weekend and then we ate some
bomb-ass Mexican food but we're like we
need to walk this off so we just went
down the restaurant and down this
mountain and we found this hammock out
of nowhere it was [ __ ] crazy
I like cut your hammock I mean you're
here camping consists of a Mexican
restaurant that's because
when is this restaurant the service
wasn't great yeah so kind of ruined our
camping trip it was it was glad but the
margaritas were hella bomb because can't
be going somewhere without a full bar
he's like man can't bang a little bit we
should no can't being again we're
working no no I I had a jory what's the
plan trying to solidify not yet the
campsite first I don't want a blast
location now my understood if you didn't
invite Steve I get it man look at dad I
get it I'll ruin you guys fun I always I
always invite the I don't dig myself a
bit of it he was inviting the shooters
first yeah I gotta cover the cover me
cover the me what do you mean I like
shooting with you guys it's Casey
you wanna keep see the gun heater that's
why we KZ hates guns he hates them I
don't know he's in Texas crazy huh
they're both Texans and they hate guns
what hold I mean I'm not against your
gun right so don't worry well thank you
just don't like it I hate guns too but I
I have a lot stop me he has guns because
he hates if somebody else could use a
gun hell yeah he needs like 20 of them
cuz well at least I told you know once I
lock it down on the Senate hour
me and TIFF are over here we're gonna be
holding my breath till we get it right
hmm oh let's call them you don't give a
[ __ ] if you invite them no I am gonna
send it I got it down a rock climb yeah
he's just like
we didn't write it's all good
I know we are being bead cap exactly
clapping oh you ain't Glanville gladion
is a stupid hipster [ __ ] when i try to
cap on like a la skyscraper rooftop with
a Ted that's a real thing just can't be
with a heart I am yeah why can't we talk
about glamping that's incredible I
thought it was like the super hit a
stupid hipster thing I want no but I'm
saying talk about it I want to talk
about it
like that's more interesting than
anything in this horde of what do you
want to know talking about no but they I
did it you're honest nobody do you want
me to throw it away we camped on a
skyscraper you're up on a skyscraper and
we did that B follows it then we
invented that [ __ ]
we invented we invented that we invented
that so we were on top of our friends
rooftop and this is like in the middle
of downtown LA like we have financial
buildings all around us we [ __ ] set
up tents we got like a like a fire pit
thing and then we just started camping
in the middle in the middle of the city
s'mores and then I got chocolate on my
face and I didn't know and that night a
bunch of mosquitos can get bit back I
like how camping on the top of the
skyscraper but if you're if you're if
you're in a tent and you're cooking out
y'all [ __ ] on the top of a skyscraper
then you're camping if you're 60 stories
down or 430 floors down and you're in a
tent you're homeless yeah
there's no difference well there's the
difference is elevation when is house
music playing it's camping okay okay is
that what it is yeah gotcha that was fun
[Music]